welcome back there's a major scandal
going on with Governor Andrew Cuomo's
deadly decision to pack nursing homes
with Kovac patients instead of asking
his brother about the disastrous
mishandling CNN's Chris Cuomo decided
he'd rather joke around instead this is
the normal swap is it true that this was
the swab that the nurse was actually
using on you and that at first it went
into your nose and disappeared so that
in scale this was the actual swab that
was being used to fit up that
double-barrel shotgun that you have
mounted on the front of your pretty face
like I don't know come on which was it's
not love this is not love great I love
this how big is your blood I mean I'm
all for humor in politics but how big is
your blind spot not to see how stupid
this is something is missing in cuomo
world it's any concept of self-awareness
first you know chris told everybody to
quarantine and then he broke his then he
he got all ticked off at trump for
trying a prescribed drug and in which
then he dosed on something less safe a
less safe version and then he always
talks about how Trump is indifferent to
suffering and he's you know turning into
carrot top with the governor of New York
as thousands have died in rest homes the
consequences of this though aren't funny
the reason why the media lionized andrew
Cuomo while the rest homes were being
ravaged was in part due to these
adorable little skits and routines on
CNN that gave them that oh isn't it
great let's tune in and watch it's so
human could you imagine
Andrew Cuomo on special report what
would have happened at Bret bear pulled
out like a giant swab they'd be calling
him indifference and death and suffering
so I have a final dumb question Chris
Cuomo Don Lemon Anderson Cooper what are
they I know what I am and I know what
Tucker is I know what Jessie is we're
commentators I know what Bill Hemmer is
and Bret Baier is in shannon bream they
are news people but there's no
distinction on
CNN of what they are so they were
allowed to portray opinion as fact and
then they dare to pass judgment on us
and their phony stentorian words which
are just absolutely laughable answer
that question what are they I don't know
Dana you know a lot of the time when
politicians act out of touch as Governor
Cuomo did in that interview it's because
they don't feel like there's going to be
accountability for their actions we know
that there are investigations now into
the nursing home policy but it just
seems like given his answers on that he
doesn't care much well he's he's he's
right and high at an 80% approval rating
right now and again I think that's
partly because remember I was saying in
the a block the national media really
went after the red state governors and
part of the consequence of that was that
there's their numbers approval ratings
are in the tank now I think the facts on
the ground will turn that around for
them
contrast that with Governor Cuomo who
look I actually enjoyed his press
briefings at the beginning I thought the
communication style was really
interesting it was almost like being at
a lecture and then however I think that
you have to question his judgment about
going on his brother's show last night
because there is a real question right
now that people want to know about the
nursing homes when he was asked about it
recently he said well I was just
following CDC guidelines but he said
Trump's CDC guidelines there were other
things that he did then he thinks you
know the Trump didn't do so he's trying
to pass off a really horrible
catastrophic decision on President Trump
and then you know going on his brother
show I don't think he knew about the
little joke that Chris Cuomo was going
to play but have it it's happened enough
that I think you have to wonder about
the judgment of the guy and why he has
an 80% approval rating yeah one these
interviews are always back-and-forth
jokey jokey in a difficult time what
about the families who have lost family
members as a result of this policy well
I mean again what you just heard from
Dana is the governor's rationale he said
that in fact the federal government was
saying that you don't want to overburden
the hospitals and if it's
possible keep those folks in the senior
citizens homes I turned out to be a
terrible decision and I think
everybody's got to take responsibility
in terms of that skit that we saw I
think you're right on Katie I mean I
just you know I think we're going
through a tough time I don't think
that's much to laugh about but I don't
think in all honesty that anybody's
gonna stick that huge swab up their nose
nobody's gonna do that I mean when you
know by comparison you see people
hoarding and talking about hydro clocks
at chlorine or whatever after the
president says he's taking that and you
know again high risk no proven benefit
for you know I mean I don't know why the
president's playing medicine man and
putting on his own skits I just don't
like it I think people should take this
moment seriously doctor-prescribed back
to him Cuomo
what did Cuomo yeah White House darker
this segment is not about
hydroxychloroquine it's about the fact
that Andrew Cuomo the governor of New
York had a policy in place that required
hospital in two nursing homes to spread
the who then spread the disease around
and killed thousands of people as a
result of an executive order so that's
what we're talking about we're not
talking about hydroxychloroquine Jesse
well just on hydroxychloroquine the only
thing I would add would be that this
Andrew Cuomo the governor ordered 70,000
doses of it for New York so if it's
really that bad why the order 70,000
doses one the other thing is the CDC
guidelines did not suggest you bring in
infected patients into nursing homes
this is what it said I read it it said
if you are to do that you have to have
vigilant testing and a space designated
within the nursing home to quarantine
new patients that are infected for 14
days before you mix them in with the
rest of the population Andrew Cuomo
didn't do either of that the other thing
is thing with the interview this is like
how all of the media interviews
Democrats
it's like interviewing a family member
it's honestly like a younger brother
interviewing an older brother you know
you're like you you're in all of the
older brother your little skin
Aird of making the older brother mad
because he could kick your butt and you
just tread lightly and you try to make
him laugh so he likes you it's the same
way Democrats are interviewed all of the
time and just one more thing some
producer had to create those huge swaps
so it wasn't just like you know Cuomo
had this great idea and just dragged it
out of the basement like this went
through a few levels before it got on
air yeah they went to the prop
department anyway I think they called
carrot top carrot top has those things
in a closet